agent Lane's eyes scanned over the
document he'd been sent the decryption
program had finished unraveling the
sensitive data that the SCP foundation's
cyber security kept hidden beneath
layers of encryption it had been a few
hours since he'd received the leaked
document sent to him from a mole that
had been active within the ranks of
foundation Personnel for some time and
as for what was on this secret document
it was an intake list the records and
names of everyone recently brought into
d-class Lane scoured the rose upon rows
of inmates violent criminals the worst
of the worst that the foundation used as
human Lab Rats then his eyes settled
over one name the exact one he'd been
looking for the true identity of a man
codenamed the hatchet a mass murderer
responsible for coordinating multiple
acts of international terrorism but to
agent Lane this man wasn't a threat to
be feared he was a bait in a trap for
something far
the global occult Coalition had long
been the face of officially sanctioned
legitimacy in the fight against the
anomalous while the SCP Foundation
operated in a more clandestine fashion
the GOC was operated by and acted under
the authority of the United Nations they
were mandated with policing the
Paranormal World a role nobody in the
GOC took lightly their ultimate goal was
a world rid of all anomalies while the
foundation opted for containment the
Coalition preferred extermination but
despite this fundamental difference in
their operational structures the two
organizations maintained a fragile
Alliance which is why Agent Lane needed
bait in order for his plan to work the
objective was simple kill
scp-096 also known as the shy guy an
anomalous entity with a long
disproportionate human body that could
use impossible speeds to kill anyone
that looked at its face even through an
image that was is what worried the GOC
it seemed all too easy for scp-096 to be
used as a weapon especially for
assassinations it wouldn't take much for
the foundation to mail a photo of
scp-096 to anyone say a politician who
opposed them or the head of another
group of Interest then all they'd have
to do is sit back and wait as scp-096
dispatched its unwitting Target along
with any witnesses that happened to see
it appear so the Coalition had decided
it was time to take the shy guy off the
board before anyone got any unsavory
ideas but there was still one issue with
that given the GOC and SCP foundation's
rocky relationship agent Lane had been
instructed to leave no trace of the
coalition's involvement he needed
someone else to be responsible for the
actual elimination of scp-096 so that
the GOC could deny any and all
involvement that's when he'd gotten the
idea who better to call on for a covert
strictly off the book's Mission only one
of the world's most elite special forces
units with no affiliation to the GOC
whatsoever Delta Force engineering a
scenario where Lane could get the Deltas
to take out scp-096 was going to be
tricky he couldn't give them a direct
order to kill the creature that could
too easily lead back to the GOC so The
Mastermind behind this Mission needed to
think outside of the box how could he
get the attention of Delta Force well by
offering up one of the World's Most
Wanted terrorists after all Delta Force
was renowned for undertaking missions
that involved counter-terrorism as well
as the securing and sometimes
elimination of high-value targets and
that was where the hatchet came into
plan given the severity and extreme
nature of as many crimes he was
certainly considered high value by the
US government however it was while
awaiting trial that the hatchet had
disappeared under mysterious
circumstances the official story was
that he had died in prison following a
fight with another inmate but rumors
circulated about an escape attempt of
course neither were correct now agent
Lane knew the truth the foundation had
him which means he was within the reach
of the GOC issuing a coded command to
his mole working inside the SCP
Foundation Lane instructed that the
hatchet would be making an escape of
swords at least that's how it would
appear but it would be completely staged
under the cover of night the mold
drugged and kidnapped the hatchet
breaking open an air vent and making it
look like someone had crawled their way
through nobody had and instead the
hatchet was carried unconscious to a
foundation vehicle the mole had hotwired
if he drove off in his own car the
foundation would be able to trace the
Escape back to him and then the GOC
bundling the terrorist into the trunk
the mold drove several miles away from
the foundation's site to an extraction
point where agent Lane was waiting so
here's how you're going going to lure
out the Delta Force the mole said as he
and Lane lifted the hatchet aboard the
chopper but how are you going to get
scp-096 to come out too Foundation keeps
it crying in that cell they can't stop
it getting out when someone sees it
though right lane replied yeah it moves
way too fast the mole confirmed all
someone has to do is look at it and it
can get out even when even when they
look at a picture of it the agent
finished his sentence Oh
the mole gasped realization spreading
across his face are from the hatch in
here isn't just bait to lure out Delta
Force agent Lane explained he's bait for
both
scp-096 and Delta will both be coming
after him that way as far as the
foundation knows
scp-096 will be killed during a standard
Delta Force mission to recapture an
on-the-run terrorist Mastermind and
meanwhile the GOC gets complete
deniability was nothing to do with us we
weren't involved
perfect scapegoat the mole commented
thing is if this is meant to be such a
covert Mission then why risk security by
telling me dead man don't talk agent
Lane replied quietly pulling a silenced
handgun from his holster and squeezing
the trigger firing three times for good
measure with the loose end tied up
nothing linked the global cult coalition
to the hatchet's apparent Escape sure
enough the foundation fell for it hook
line and sinker while they were busy
locking down the facility sealing the
air vents that they believed their
d-class prisoner had escaped through
agent Lane had the hatchet handcuffed
securely under lock and key the
helicopter took them a short distance to
a quiet airstrip where they boarded an
Uncharted plane to a safe house to avoid
any further links to the GOC Lane had to
transport the hatchet as Off the Grid as
possible until he got him to their
destination even then the safe house
couldn't be one that the GOC had ever
used before any Link in the foundation
or Delta Force would smell or rat the
leaked intelligence that was soon
received by Delta Force seemed to
confirm their worst fears Not only was
the hatchet still alive but he was free
and apparently hiding out in a safe
house while they would never publicly
acknowledge the unit's activities the
Department of Defense issued an
objective to Delta Force Tracked Down
The Hatchet to his current location and
either capture him or kill him a squad
of some of the most highly trained
United States troops were assembled
before joining Delta Force most of them
had been recruited from the elite 75th
Ranger regiment as well as from other
branches of Special Forces and The Wider
U.S army the team wasn't told by their
Commander whose identity was classified
where they were going all the
information they were given was only the
essentials just that there was a high
value Target holed up in a safe house
although they had no idea there would
actually be two only the second was
unlike anything the Deltas had ever seen
Agent Lane was watching over hidden
infrared cameras they were sent to cut
out the minute the lights came on no
point in going through all this trouble
only to see 096 on his feed and be
killed too silently using all the skills
and stealth that they had been trained
in the squad of Delta Force operators
slipped into the safe house their
movements were perfectly synchronized
practiced hours and hours at a time they
checked Corners two would sweep one room
with a building whilst two more
protected them and none of them would
move on until they confirmed that the
area was clear floor by floor they
worked their way up the building
ascending closer and closer to where the
hatchet was The Operators were fully
expecting to meet arm resistance from
the hatchet's Loyalists when they
arrived the fact that the place was so
quiet didn't seem right in fact none of
the lights were on either the Delta
Force unit needed to wear night vision
just to navigate their way around
despite it seeming suspicious none of
them could have guessed it was
intentional agent Lane had set
everything up to work perfectly arriving
at one room the Special Forces troops
could hear the found of someone behind
the door their voice was muffled like
something was obscuring their mouth and
preventing them from speaking this was
it the team lined up against the nearest
wall and placed an explosive charge on
the door with a mighty explosion the
entrance burst wide open and the team
filed in weapons trained on the room's
Soul occupant they could see through the
hazy green of their goggles a figure sat
in a chair no restrained to a chair with
something in front of him it looked like
a frame a photograph and a frame who
sits in front of a photo in the dark
suddenly the lights came up causing the
operator's night vision goggles to beam
bright white straight into their eyes
the second the lights came on the
camera's agent Lane was watching through
cut off and he purged the hard drive
they were connected to leaving no
recording no evidence of the situation
he'd engineered meanwhile as the room
was illuminated the first of the Delta
Force Team to take off his goggles saw
who it was tied to the chair it was the
hatchet Bound by his wrists and ankles
eyes pried open so he couldn't look away
from the framed photo in front of him a
photo of
scp-096 suddenly within the blink of an
eye the tall slender creature had
appeared in the room with the captive
terrorist the Deltas removing their
goggles turned in horror to c096
slaughtering their target and the moment
they looked at it the Wailing shy guy
started bearing down on them too contact
their Captain yelled open fire hostile
contact they started shooting their
bullets having little effect on the
looming wiry monster as it came at each
of the squad one by one the muzzle
flashes eliminated the oncoming anomaly
those brief glimpses of it flickering of
gunfire made it look all the more
horrifying screams filled the room
echoing through the building as scp-096
decimated the team that had unknowingly
been sent in to kill it one of the
Deltas was still struggling with his
night vision unable to detach them from
his face thanks to a clasp that had
gotten stuck all he could hear were his
Squad mates around him being killed but
with no way of seeing what was happening
the captain gurgled he sounded hurt but
the operator couldn't see how badly or
what had attacked him shoot the thing
shoot him now I can't see sir he yelled
back goggles still strapped to his face
eyes shut to keep out the Searing
whiteness 10 o'clock the captain
replied directing his subordinate to aim
his weapons slightly to the left there
was a sickening twisting sound and the
captain's voice cut out the private
fired his shot winging the creature it
whimpered then seemed to vanish as
quickly as it had arrived pulling a
combat knife from the sheath on his belt
the operator was able to cut the strap
keeping the goggles over his eyes when
his vision cleared he looked around to
see an empty room smeared in blood even
the hatchet hadn't survived killed in
the chair he'd been held in the operator
took a closer look at the photo the
terrorist had been made to look directly
at it was hideous tall and thin arms
that looked too long and a huge mouth
and now it was behind him it would never
stop killing anyone that looked at it
wants an anomaly of your own check out
scpswag.com for high quality SCP merch
now go and check out can scp-096 chase
its victims across the Multiverse and
scp-096 tale a lesson in power for more
096 antics